i believe
is that with an unknown regarding what
the salary cap is going to be
it's going to be difficult for his next
suitor
to know what it can afford to pay him if
it's 180 that's one contract if they
somehow get the tv deals done and you
mentioned that as well today in football
morning in america and i think one of
the motivations is have a a giant 100
billion dollar pile of money that they
could shift around and maybe pump up the
salary cap a little bit this year then
you could pay him a little bit more but
i think for some of these teams
they may need to wait and see what the
caps going to be before they can make a
meaningful offer to jj watt
mike
you said it exactly right i mean
there is no way that any team right now
can know
exactly where it is
entering free agency until it knows the
salary cap number
and i was told by somebody in super bowl
week that
this person thought that the
announcement of these deals could be
about a month away
or within a month i think were the exact
words
but
what was so interesting about the
conversations i've had about this tv
deal
is not that there's a race to the finish
line it isn't like oh we have to get it
done now
but i think for the first time
you were seeing
teams look at the nfl office and say in
essence figuratively hurry up and finish
this we could really use some help this
year and so i think you're going to see
the tv deals get done by let's say pick
a date like march 10th
so that going into
free agency which starts i think if i'm
not mistaken on march 16th
or 17th
but to take
actual exact numbers into free agency
rather than just guessing what it would
be and where that really would influence
you know a guy like jj watt is let's say
a team that is really
not in great cap shape you know not it
not has millions to spend like say the
indianapolis colts if it's a team really
snug up against the cap and has a lot of
internal problems anyway
they're going to need extra money to
spend on j.j watt that's why i think the
tv deals there's a lot of motivation
from teams to the league to get that
deal done by about you know the other
wild card and i'm not sure they're going
to have answers by march 17. the
anticipated ticket sales the anticipated
attendance for 2021 right that is a way
that they can have greater certainty
about the money that's going to flow
through the coffers this year and that
they could then use to pump up the cap
but
this this urgency to get the tv deals
done by the middle of march seems to be
part of a broader play to it to at least
make it
a little more fair for some of these
teams and you can say well hey if you
decided to go overboard on the cap in
past years and you're in a horrible spot
like the saints are they're not in as
bad of a spot as they were because of
the drew brees restructuring but
uh no one expected this this isn't
something you plan for they do contracts
peter planning for the cap to keep going
up this is if it goes to 180 an 18.2
million dollar depression per team that
no one ever really budgeted for plan for
anticipated and that's why i think it
becomes important but that's why it's
going to as a practical matter delay jj
watts final destination until people
know what the cap is because he falls in
that very broad gulf of guys who
aren't superstars he was but he's not
now at 32 and given his injury history
and given the obvious reduction in
skills you're going to see when you've
been banged on and doubled and triple
teamed all your career you're not going
to go out and just write your own number
you have to wait and the rookies the
younger guys their salaries are set in
stone because they're so low he's in
this middle class that is going to get
squeezed by the cap and the question is
how squeezed is oh so
i suspect tom condon is going to have
that small universe of teams
and it's going to come down to who can
pay what and when they know and and it
may be that the team that wants to get
him is going to have to take a leap of
faith and say we're just going to put
this number on him and if we have to
come up with cap space somewhere else so
be it if they want him badly enough to
sign him before march 17.
you know and that's why when you look at
a lot of the teams that might be logical
suitors
um
you know like
to me the packers because clearly i
think he would want the packers to be
interested in him you know the packers
according to over the cap are at
uh 203 million uh the chiefs are at 207
million the steelers 215 million you
almost have to look at this and say
let's be a little bit realistic now
on some of the teams that if you really
want to jump out there and get an edge
and try to find a team now you know
we're talking more like you know say the
browns and the colts
and and and the one other team that i
think is really really interesting
that's teetering
right at the middle of solvency in the
cap this year is the buffalo bills
and to me i i look at
what a smart general manager brandon
bean is and he has to know
that you know for one year
it would really be great to have the
leadership and the play of jj watt on a
young and growing and very you know
influential he could be a very
influential figure on that defense
you had reposted a podcast that you did
with jj watt when the texans had some
practices with the green bay packers and
it's pretty clear he'd like to play for
the packers if it came down to green bay
and pittsburgh where he could play with
his two brothers because i've thought
all year long you know during football
season when they played and the idea of
j.j watt wearing the steelers uniform
and lining up with tj how how great that
would be for them as a family
but between them and the packers which
way do you think he would fall if he can
all other things equal all the numbers
are equal same offer which team would he
go with the packers of the steelers
my guess is he'd go with the packers and
that's all it is mike he'd go with the
packers because he grew up looking
through the fence at training camp and
saying oh my god these guys are larger
than life figures
um
and there's something else about this
mike i've always sensed that
jj watt really really loves his brother
and and you know that's not breaking
news
and i wonder if the thought would go
through his mind
if i show up in pittsburgh am i going to
suck all the air out of the room you
know because i'm the
you know three-time defensive player of
the year and
and i'm this popular guy and all that
stuff and
and i i just wonder if he would look at
that as
sort of infringing on tj's turf maybe he
wouldn't and maybe tj would beg him to
come i don't know
but to me i look at it and and i just
think green bay really makes so much
sense he wants to win this year
uh green bay's got an excellent chance
to win this year and the one other
factor in this mic
is that
i believe at the end of the day although
he does want his money who doesn't i
believe at the end of the day
he's going to play for the team that he
really wants to play for if
that team is interested in him and and
again
could this be like a charles woodson
at age 30
showing up in green bay
you know the difference is charles
woodson still had some prime years left
j.j watt might have won
two with the outside prime years left
but he might not have so i don't know if
brian goodkins is the al who is the
ultimate
practical guy
i just don't know if he's going to say
yep let's go get j.j watt we'll have to
wait and see
and the signing of charles woodson came
in 2006 after brett favre went public
during one of his annual will i or won't
i retire musings and aaron rodgers had
already been on the roster for a year
but favre complained that they didn't go
out and sign guys in free agency they
hadn't had a marquee free agent since
reggie white they signed charles woodson
that year and he ultimately contributed
to a super bowl win by aaron rodgers but
but
this gets back to the the topic of the
week post super bowl quarterbacks
flexing their muscle either publicly or
privately to get help to compile a
potential super team
what is aaron rodgers saying to brian
gouda kunst and or matt lafleur and or
mark murphy about jj watt were there
text messages instantly sent let's go
get this guy
that's part of this drama that we may
not know the answer to but it's playing
out in the aftermath of tom brady
gathering up all of his buddies in tampa
and winning a super bowl russell wilson
making it clear he'd like to do the same
thing if not in seattle somewhere else
aaron rodgers with that team that's 13-3
two consecutive years couldn't punch
through to the super j.j watt what will
he say
to management and what will management
say to him and will that spur them to
action peter
i mean
yeah i'm asking that more and more now
mike you know in the wake of you know
what russell wilson has said in the wake
of uh desean watson wanting out you know
in the wake of matthew stafford getting
his way in getting out
mike you know the rules are being
rewritten as we speak
and i mean we are going to see how
really classic
and classically trained general managers
quite honestly like brian gouda kingston
green bay like john schneider in seattle
and you know who's they both come from
the ron wolfe tree essentially
ron wolf ted thompson
those guys you know basically
you know what they believe mike they
believe what what ron wolf believe hey
listen i'll scout the players hey
coaches you coach the players and hey
players you play
okay and
and i think that is what is sort of up
for
a little bit of a debate now
and that is up for
how is the these
this tectonic plate
of
classic old time football
is it going to change you know mike when
i covered the new york giants in the 80s
you think of it now and it seems so
preposterous
that
bill parcells had zero
zero say
on who the team was going to draft
okay it was george young the general
manager tom boister the personnel guy
that's who decided who the players were
going to be then they gave him to bill
parcells and they belong to parcells
and it seems like such an uh such an odd
way and look that that franchise won two
super bowls in that time so who's to say
it's wrong all i'm saying is that it is
so different from the way the nfl is
done today i can't imagine
what george young would have said
if phil sims came out in an interview
after they won the super bowl and said
you know i want some more say in how we
pick players around here george would
have he would have still been laughing
even though he's dead
[Laughter]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports